nick nick baskerville had asked what
types of jobs can you get can you do
like pursuing stand-up you know like
warm-up comic professional hosts writers
for shows
um
yeah like so other jobs you can do
beyond just stand-up comedy i think yeah
hosting is a big one i think
you are learning the skill of public
speaking it's people's biggest fears
so
if you could public speak
you can do a lot of different things
i've hosted like awards shows i've
hosted
um like uh like a company parties and
things like that i mean i've been asked
to do a wedding before but it was
it was a college friend and they wanted
the buddy deal and it was really far
away and i was like nah gee
um but
yeah you can uh
[Laughter]
you can do a lot more yeah writing is a
good one uh writing for a tv show
writing funny copy for like um
advertising is another thing i've seen
people do
yeah yeah there's tons of comedy jobs
out there for sure um i'd also say just
know that like as a comedian at the core
you're a writer and there's tons of
different types of writing gigs that you
can get i also say like just the
practice of like podcasting hosting
different types of stuff that's
entertaining is so important i remember
the shalewa interview
um
she mentioned on uh on hot breath she
mentioned
she was just like yeah like producers
and
people they'd be like oh so you do
comedy
what else oh you're right what else like
they want to see like the list of like
all the different stuff that you do
because it's like oh well we don't have
a stand-up show so what else can you do
if we're trying to put you on television
there's not a stand-up show on
television so it's like okay what are
your skills you know noah garden
schwartz is a writer on the marvelous
miss maisel yep but he's a stand-up
right and it is a stand-up like themed
show so they have a lot of standups as
writers for the show itself but they
also have people that are not stand ups
as writers um and so it's just about
just leveraging that comedy writing
skill yeah also other performance like
when we talk about public speaking you
know i mean acting is clearly there like
you can do improv i've done
i've done like team building
facilitation for companies like it's
like team building games and activities
and they wanted someone like fun
interactive to run it like
so there's a lot of different things you
can use because you're developing the
skill of
engaging an audience which is
very difficult and very rare so if you
can do it you can find other avenues in
this beyond just standing there with a
microphone
yo it's
you know i always say
spotify didn't pay
joe rogan
he's great at comedy
those are just facts you mean like
because
but he used that comedy skill
in his podcast he used the comedy skill
on when he's hosting shows
so yeah just know that there's other
avenues to getting paid other than
standout yeah